ou pas
c'est à moi voilà à ce genre hamas gagne
encore inutile aurier il disait que
qu'il fait beau ouais je le refuse de
continuer à jouer
citons chez pioc ne se tait pas en fait
il a droit d'être gay nous c'est ne
prouve qu'ils ne te donne pas des
indications sur mon jeu ou s'il n'a pas
conscience mais tarde à prendre son
langage je joue de trek je viens de
jouer cette carte il y à une minute
tu as triché non non pas du tout c'est
mou j'ai seulement souhaité avant rendre
d'autres avaient fait plusieurs parents
ne s'est pas agi en quelques jeunes y
aurait que tu avais un tel don de
magicien tu peux ainsi faire apparaître
n'importe quoi pour moi c'est très
facile tu peux me faire une
démonstration d'une station vous
évidemment on est bien sur tu sais par
exemple je pourrais je pourrais te faire
un autre classique du à points qui sort
du chapeau
malheureusement nous n'avons pas de
chapeau erreur rien dans la réserve
je me souviens de la delà de la formule
magique pour nous la part la plus
intense et sa pilule rapide us lapidot
bof bof alors ça ne semble pas 35 on
attend évidemment je joue bien nous
attends je recommence chapiteau rapido
limpide aux chapélies bus bof bof
alors rien ça rallonge comprend pas ton
jeu je recommence réputation si tu n'as
pas n'importe qui avec un peu
d'entraînement peu sera paraître on a
plein de château n'importe qui sauf toi
j'avoue chapiteau lapidus rappaz liebus
la palio rappaz niveau ça chapeau
et le jour lien h2o a bien évidemment je
comprends ouais regarde il n'y avait eu
plus d'un chapeau une puce à la mort de
la trêve et il a fait fuir ou ça use
bof on la regarde une puisqu'il a mordu
le lapin qui était dans le chapeau je le
vois rien et comment était-il ce lapin
mon cou maintenant mon jouet qui les
commet et et et j'en sais rien taquin
région détectée vers moi je suis
seulement dit 'tiens je ne vois pas ta
puce et tu as inventé toute cette
histoire de magie pour me cacher que tu
triches aux cartes et bien sûr à vous
passer de plus qui était dans le chapeau
tu va la sentir garde sur toi oulala ça
me chatouille au germoir des plus est